[Music]
i find being under 30 to be a huge
advantage in my industry you know
healthcare has really not been
re-envisioned right how we're practicing
one-on-one therapy today looks pretty
similarly to how freud practiced therapy
120 years ago
right and because i haven't spent 20
years in mental health care because i
wasn't even trained formally as a
clinician i'm not biased by what the
system today looks like right i have the
luxury and the privilege of being able
to identify gaps and and to even to feel
within me that doesn't feel right right
whereas if i had been trained in this
system if i'd worked in it for 20 years
for 30 years it's just so much harder to
identify flaws right what works and what
doesn't work and i get to have such a
fresh pair of eyes and to envision a
completely different future because of
it it's a health it's a conservative
industry
it should be it's healthcare to a degree
and so um
there have been certain advantages
there's the things that come with the
youth energy
travel sleepless all those things that
just come with like
youth and all that stuff for the
industry itself it's not like i'm
relating to a consumer base that's my
age i'm relating to different people
it's a
gray hair industry suit and tie
so i would say that's been a
disadvantage i'm always the youngest
person in a room um
for better or for worse i have a beard
which helps me not show my age but
that's that is what it generally is i
struggled for a while because i'd walk
into a room and people wouldn't assume
that i'm competent i don't know if it
has to do as much as me being under 30
as me being a woman i think that's
really been a big variable in that
i think it's also been an advantage
especially for building a team right we
have
a lot of people who came from very
traditional biopharma companies they've
had to deal with honestly really
terrible male-led hierarchical cultures
they've never like seen or very rarely
seen as a woman's ceo and had the
opportunity to work under a woman's ceo
and so i can never promise a perfect
culture we definitely don't have a
perfect culture at loyal no company does
but i can at least promise that we're
different right like we're questioning
the variables that have been set for a
long time and that's allowed me to build
this really amazing team around this
really cool idea
in a period of time that
has been quite rapid the mortgage
business is a very old business it's a
part of the us economy it's a huge part
of it it's 20 percent of gdp and it's
something that everybody looks at as an
old sort of uh you know
main street type business it's not
something that like young people get
into especially today in this uh sort of
environment so that's part one of it
which makes it really hard to get into
the second thing is it's again extremely
regulated so you're not allowed to just
do the sort of you know old dodge of
venture companies of uh move quickly and
break things right you're not allowed to
break things here you're actually
supposed to think about well this is
this regulation i need to follow it and
as a result it's very hard to build a
business very quickly because if you
were to make a mistake you can get fined
by all the different regulators even if
you're trying to do the right thing
balancing those two is really the hard
part in this business and i tell the
people in the company hey we need to
move quickly but break quote-unquote
limited things so that's what we try to
do over and over again but
perfecting that is what makes this a
successful business
you